put it behind you those games like that happen to
everybody it's gone over cach long snapshot saved
by oder and he will hang on Tyler San up there
with this line with Marchman and Duane duan's
loose here he's been hot his first season as a
member of the star Cent pass goes off a skate
face off to the right to vasileski Jamie Ben
wins it back to the line hayin in with a drive
and a Save By baseli no rebound Thomas Harley
young 23-year-old defenseman who's got goals
in backto back games coming in he dumps it down
the ice here's Ben out in front save by baseski
right to the doorstep was Johnston what a chance
that was now here's Harley at Cross another stop
by B that Snapshot from the high slot off the
Stick of Ben shoulder and then square up it's
one of the hardest saves that there is look at
him track that puck but get the G gain field
back again B he's got a couple of games under
his belt he'll be just fine St goes back to COV
and there's a big stop by Oden jerk selli dumps
it back in for the lightning Arena around the
boards waiting for there was marshman here's
C with a shot and now it's a couple of great
a chances for the lightning R Nikita CRA trying
to force his way to the net hin ball up the wall
cut off by Stan goes back to headman headman
in shoots s Love Save made by ainger what was
running through your mind being surrounded by
19,000 fans standing on their feet cheering for
your brother what was that like for you and
your family yeah very emotional you know my
kid brother yeah stand down all and we're going
to end it on that guys back to you ni COV it's
a 10 game point streak now and it's one one
nothing Tampa Bay to Victor Hedman from his
brother the lightning were on the full court press
Nikita COV disappeared in the corner for a second
but great goal scorers do watch the replay and
none of the Defenders see him coming they're all
turned in a different direction and go oh where
did he come from sudor had a guy but nobody had
COV these guys just learn how to disappear for a
minute turn around he's creeping up on 300 career
goals he's got the bu again get to the C J across
and he almost had Point here turn into the chis
rebound for Point save by AER how many times
have we said that radish lost the puck there
a save by vasileski again that one on steel
now up ahead aim on trying to turn the corner
on Lindell centers it back across and he missed
Paul he was in traffic and checked Dallas back
to the way in TR transition stepping it over the
line there's Lindell little bouncer handled by
balinski pass in the middle here's Glen Denny
shoots save rebound Watson was there but it was
knocked away there's a couple of guys that come
out used the ice skated i' love that he didn't
just stand way back and make guys come back to him
he got it he's been able to manage his games sud
is one of those guys he looks like he's playing
the game at half Speed Most of the time cuz he's
smart he knows where to be early yeah Sean got
half a step on headman San feeds it down low sharp
angled shot Basi down makes the save Dallas across
pavelski F shoots and he just missed bar post
Tampa Bay in desperate need of a change here's
the feed to his big stop by baseli let's take a
look at some of the saves that he's made because
Dallas did have a heck of a shift they got some
fresh guys out there VY moving left to his right
there beautiful leg save there rupe hints on the
Move face off one to the line trying to
spy coo off in the corner they get him
and this one is left for chernak chernak
along the goal line out in front for Celli
SC Anthony Celli makes it two nothing Tampa Bay
watch chernack take that drop pass going in
opposite directions with COV but see how he
waited there for a second he didn't just dump
it in there watch him hold it right here no
not yet not yet not yet he waited for Celli to
get the stick down lightning here comes Point
through Center Stepping Over The Line lead to
rutra kutra gets it back and that shot stopped
by tinger gutov to point Bren Point rolling
back of the corner against hitch nice pass COV
rips it off the iron good stick for lundell
but watch raen Point doing what he does but
CRA just knifes his way in between two Dallas
Players they're busy watching braen point cuz
they're afraid he start to really wind up
not many goal tenders would have kept that
one moving with a guy coming right on him
here's Johnson with a shot save rebound Sav
by balowski again it's still two nothing and
this is why one save and then that one right
there Suter looks it back to Fox up up to
the point for Hanley Hanley across delandre
R shot blocked and here comes Glen Denning
trying to break away Glen Denning is in
SC Luke Glen Denning the former star makes it
three nothing BS and that one hurt too oh to
get up trying to get the shot through delri
gets it blocked and Glen Denning has to stay
on his backand to protect the puck it goes in
before he slides into the goal tender they'll
of course take a look at that but he does a
good job of protecting it there Hanley was
coming across and hanley's job and he was doing it
right don't let him get onto his forehead make him
nervous enough to make that play on the back
hand can you make it on the back hand and the
answer was yes back on the boards COV to hedmond
Reaching Forward is CRA out in front a point point
across s goes Sav by Andra big stop there here's
headman his shot tip wide Victor Hedman trying to
find aimont along the left going boards Dallas
back on the attack here's a backhand attempt
rebound saved by baselski again he's already
in early position he's already figured out
what the play is going to be this one was just
about staying calm look at him snatch that one
right out of the air the original backand control
the rebound get some help from your defenseman up
the play is Hegel bar ble and Hegel up there
the four check bar ble got it forelli backand
scores Anthony selli with his second goal of
the night you can make it four nothing Tampa
Bay couple of gold came into this game
with one goal in his last 10 but this is
about the turnover on the for che getting
pucks deep and constantly putting pressure
on the D Hegel with a terrific job along the
wall wall there that was a couple of touches
Bari ble was in there but they just raised
kofs and both defenseman were in the same
court taken off the puck there by Jano Lindell
Puck knock down again by Jano lightning step
in three on two here's J head shot and they
hit the other post and then coming back the
other way again Tander Jano nice job and he
had his stick checked couldn't get it in now
here's SE he's in stop by baselski again or
nothing lightning Andre baseli the big cat is
back the data stars is something
about the Stars this is shut out
number six against the data stars
33d of his career Andre vasileski